je m'appelle sylvain ferrai pied de
poule j'ai 30 ans et je suis à internes
en médecine générale
les deux tours je suis né à villeurbanne
près de lyon
et ensuite j'ai beaucoup bougé pour me
retrouver
du coup actuellement en stage à vierzon
[Musique]
découvre vraiment tout mais c'est vrai
que je vois pas forcément non plus voilà
être en ville plutôt une maison en
campagne assez indépendante on va dire
des autres les lotissements
quitte à être à la campagne autant
vraiment y être on peut vraiment habiter
à la campagne
à voir la qualité de vie de la campagne
c'est à dire l'espace
la proximité de la terre et pour autant
de ne pas être isolé et pouvoir rester
en contact avec les gens qui nous aident
plutôt voilà en maison de santé avec les
maisons de santé
rien qu'au niveau du contact c'est vrai
que nous débarquer dans une région qu'on
connaît pas forcément le fait déjà
d'avoir des collègues avec qui on peut
manger à midi ça permet de créer un
contact eux aussi légèrement ils tendent
à habiter pas très loin donc déjà ça ne
me crée notre petit réseau et je pense
que c'est aussi ça qui est très agréable
la campagne l'ex voilà avec les styles
désagréments
le
bull on a quand même plus de trajets je
trouve qu'en ville on prend notre
voiture vraiment la voiture je veux dire
c'est le socle sur lequel on se base
donc on est quand même là plus ou moins
pressés c'est que comme moi je fais
beaucoup de route au niveau du travail
il ya d'autres types de stress c'est sûr
mais c'est vrai que le fait déjà d'avoir
de l'espace c'est quand même très
agréable